[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
baby vader and who else is here after
staying up to watch the disney investor
day event
even though i didn't go to bed until 4am
you know i couldn't miss a moment of the
mandalorian
and this video we're going to be
breaking down everything you need to
know about the latest episode
last time we saw grogu reach out to
another jedi in the galaxy
but before we could find out who the
little rascal was snatched
up by muff gideon faster than i
cancelled my razor crest pre-order
joined by bill burr's mayfeld episode 7
follows mando and co
as they try and attempt to get the
location of gideon's ship
before we get into that though if you've
been enjoying the video so far i'd
massively appreciate it if you hit the
thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss our recap of
the finale
anyway the entry is filled to the brim
with cool little easter eggs and details
and we pick up almost immediately after
the events of episode six
with cara dune going to a republican
scrapyard in order to free mayfield
i was expecting this entry to be some
sort of prison escape
but i guess it's more about who you know
rather than what you know
as she manages to get him out there
without a hitch at all
cara was of course made a marshal
recently so this clearance allows her to
just walk in and out with the character
unfortunately nick frost isn't in this
episode which is a bit strange
as his face was shown in the lineup last
week but it turns out that it must have
just been a cameo as he's completely
missing
however the junkyard is filled to the
brim with easter eggs including tie
fighter cockpits
x-wing engines an atsd and the 8080
inspired cranes that we saw in episode
3. we join a security droid as he goes
up to prisoner 34667
aka mayfeld you may remember in the
prisoner episode from last season
that these droids were throughout and it
was said that the republic's reliance on
them
caused serious issues as we know the
first order rose due to the instability
that they created
and we very much get the idea from
mayfeld that things are just as bad
no matter who's in power now i love that
boba fett has cleaned up his armor
and i always wondered why it looked like
crap in comparison to django's
i guess you don't know what you've got
till it's gone but he's ironed out all
of the kinks
except the dint in his helmet and it
looks like he actually cares this
time now symbolically i took this as
meaning that he was once more proud to
be a mandalorian
star wars law has kind of gone back and
forth over the past couple of decades
as to whether django and boba were truly
part of the creed
however last we confirmed that the
former was indeed a foundling
and therefore they are thus the cleaning
of this armor not only shows the pride
he's able to take in wearing it again
but also that he may have been accepted
as one finally
that's just how i took it but let me
know below if you disagree
now it turns out that mayfeld knows how
to get imperial information
due to his old protocols and these will
help mando get back grogu
korra also says they have his kid and
the wording on this
is very important to me as it finally
shows that the pair are pretty much
father and son
the [ __ ] bit of slave 1 rotate as they
ascend into the air
and this is because the ship of course
turns on its axis in order to fly
now it's not too long before they reach
morak a tropical forest planet
that to me resembles scarif from rogue
one minus the water
turns out the empire have been mining it
for precious materials
and mining is something that we've
actually seen pop up throughout the
series
there were of course those that attacked
cobb van settlement in episode 1
and i do believe that the magistrate had
specialized in it too
because of this we further get the idea
that the empire is ransacking planets
and bleeding them dry in order to get
what they want
the target is a refinery which
specializes in rhidonium
and explosive material that will help
them carry out devastating attacks on
planets
skipping ahead a little bit here but
there is lip service paid to operation
cinder
which you'll be familiar with if you
play battlefront 2.
operation cinder was carried out several
weeks after the battle of endor
and it was viewed as a contingency plan
by the emperor to decimate massive parts
of the galaxy
so that neither the empire or its
enemies outlived him
because the rhidonium is heavily
protected the group have to sneak in
and after commandeering a juggernaut
escorting the precious material
they all head in the juggernauts have
changed quite heavily in design
and whereas previously they were more
like tanks here we can see an
almost train-like design that allows
them to transport a lot of cargo
in order to reach the coordinates a face
scan must be carried out
so you have to either be in the system
or not registered at all
cara is with the republic fenik is
wanted by the isp
and boba fett or rather jango's face
is absolutely everywhere now mando
initially refuses to show his
but he has a change of heart which we'll
discuss later in the episode
they put on the helmets of two troopers
but during the ride
mayfeld actually removes his now he says
he doesn't know how you people can wear
it
but clarifies that he meant mandalorians
and not nerf herders
which i still can't believe that leia
said
now here just winds me up that now here
we can start to see the design of the
empire trooper helmet and how it's
changed
originally they were more in line with
mandalorian helmets
before they began to shift the classic
stormtrooper that we saw throughout the
original trilogy
however for the sequel trilogy things
changed more to
a sort of slit with the rise of the
first order
and that design is of course present
here too the pair talk back and forth
about how one's allegiances tend to be
formed by where they are born
and that in some ways mando is a slave
to the beliefs that were given to him
when he was a child he of course didn't
wear a helmet but due to being a
foundling who was then raised by a
certain sect of mandalorians
he believes that covering one's face is
the way
mayfeld sort of goes on an arc in this
episode and shows that he's a free man
that isn't confined to the beliefs that
were instilled in him growing up
similar to this mando also sort of
breaks free from the chains of belief
and removes his helmet in order to get
the coordinates for gideon's ship
mayfeld brings up alderan and mandalore
and how the beliefs of those planets
formed certain things people accepted
but that neither exists anymore so
what's the point in believing them in
the first place
rebels be watching this like are we the
baddies
now on this road we see as they pass
destroyed rydonium and
we learn that this is actually caused
for a number of reasons
if you ride too fast then it can blow up
and there's also pirates in the area
that use thermal detonators to destroy
who they see as invaders
i wonder if these pirates these pirates
can hook me up with hbo maxey
anyway mando is actually a cracked shot
which i found funny as stormtroopers are
typically terrible
and though he runs out of ammo he
manages to fend them off until ties and
troopers arrive
these lads remind me of my wife a bit
because she likes to ride on
ian who is our postman hey anyway
this uh the idea of ty's arriving backs
up the point that mayfield was trying to
make
in that once you get to see things from
a person's point of view
you can see how they believe themselves
to be the only way to live
however all cultures are like this even
though they contradict one another
and thus nothing is really true it adds
a lot of depth to the episode
and i loved how we actually had some
heroic music as the troopers showed up
now upon entering the facility we can
see what are also
very similar to scarf troopers but hey
as this is a different planet
they're obviously not called this and
more act troopers it is
now mayfeld spots a terminal in the
officer's mess
but he notices that his old commander
valen hess
is there too he pretty much walks in and
out
and looks very suspicious i must say
mayfeld seems like the only one who can
do it as the terminal has to scan your
face
but mando removes his helmet and finally
gets the coordinates
just as they're about to leave hess
stops them and asks questions
but mayfield does the old me mate's
death
and not definition he's that old crap
paul that that no one likes instead
hess is played by richard brake who you
may remember from game of thrones
and also for playing joe chill and
batman begins
things seem like they're going to kick
off and it's very tense but all he wants
to do is get them a drink
so hey maybe these aren't the bad guys
after all
now unfortunately hess asks for a toast
and mayfield brings up how he was part
of operation
cinder as mentioned earlier the empire
fired on its own people
and clearly this hasn't sat well with
the character
he brings up how many troopers and their
families along with civilians died for
it
and how no matter what way you try and
spin it it wasn't for the greater good
hess brings up how the new republic is
in complete disarray
and how the supplies the pair have
dropped off are going to be used to
destroy more families
hess revels in it and it sends mayfeld
over the edge
who decides to shoot first han solo
style
the pair make their exit by using a
ledge overlooking a dam
and damn what a sick way to close things
off
fennek and kara shoot the anti-air
gunners using snipers
and slave one arrives in order to pick
up the pair
now because one of the pirates left the
rhidonium exposed on the juggernaut
mayfeld is able to shoot it and destroy
the entire facility with one blast
ties pursue the ship but using a seismic
charge which you may recall from attack
of the clones
bobber is able to take them out now what
they should do
is take mayfall back to prison however
they say that the lads dead
and this finally gives him the freedom
that he's been after mayfeld may now go
off into the galaxy and create his own
path
no longer restricted by the enforcements
made by either the empire or republic
the episode closes with mano sending a
message to the moth
and he actually quotes the character
directly in season 1
gideon said you have something i want
you may think you have some idea what
you're in possession of
but you do not in a few moments it will
be mine
it means more to me than you will ever
know
worst worst impression ever but this is
an awesome little exchange
amando changes it to he to show that he
actually cares about grogu
obviously stuff is about to go down next
week and i can't wait to see what
happens in the finale
now if you missed the disney invest
today event then you probably don't know
that there's a lot of shows such as an
ahsoka spin-off that have been announced
so it does indeed look like grand
admiral thrawn will remain as the
villain for that
as we know that moth gideon will be back
for season three
thus next week i'm actually expecting an
empire-esque ending
in which it seems like all things are
lost you know how star wars love to do
that in the middle of stuff
and say mando only gets three seasons
that it makes sense to kind of cut
things off in a cliffhanger before we
head into the final one
whichever jedi grogu reached out to
hopefully ezra
will return to help and then he'll set
up the ahsoka show i think
obviously i don't know if there's gonna
be season three or not but clearly
disney are launching a lot of star wars
shows
so who knows if they're gonna have time
for it obviously i'd love for things to
continue
but with star wars you just never know
anyway that wraps up the entry
and thanks for sticking with me until
the end don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set
to our subscribers all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the disney invest today
which will be linked on screen right now
we cover all the upcoming star wars
shows and movies
as well as what we can expect to see in
the marvel slate over the coming years
anyway without the way thank you for
sitting with me until the end of the
video
may the force be with you always i've
been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace